Anda sapen asks what is the most
revolutionary engineering challenge that
Humanity must overcome in the next 20 to
30 years well I'd say it's climate
change so how are you going to do that I
I would say it's going to be engineering
the whole earth I mean thinking of the
whole earth as a system and getting
people to work together to con to manage
that system which would be engineering
engineers use science to do what solve
problems and make uh things you can
party with break things create parties
make things and solve problems that's it
so basically climate change that's what
I would say where I is the greatest we
get we have a lot of people uh in the
world and a lot more coming and things
like water and health care and
transportation all those things that are
going to face us Engineers need to solve
yes all right that's a very reasonable
and correct answer oh it's correct
yeah